[Applause]
[Music]
i have a question
if i mention the european union what's
the first thing you think of probably
the first thing that comes to mind are
images of
brussels and public buildings or even
pictures of countries as influential as
the federal republic of germany or
france depending on where you're
watching us from you might even think
of the united kingdom rather than
countries such as lithuania or slovenia
and indeed in 2018 a survey was
conducted in 26 countries around the
world the results of which indicated
that the three most important union
states were
in this order germany france and the
united kingdom in the fourth position
following quite far behind these
countries was italy what these countries
all have in common is that they are
western european countries and the truth
is that no matter how much union there
appears to be there is still a very
clear line in the sand between those two
very different europes that today make
up
the european union we are talking about
perceptions but also about
infrastructure and deep political
social and economic differences and this
is of
increasing concern to the other europe
that is
central and eastern europe while western
european nations are deeply intertwined
through
energy and transport links the nations
of the three seas remain relatively
disconnected from each other
and you will say so what's this about
the nations of the three seas
well the three seas initiative is a
project that was created precisely to
solve
all of these problems seeing its name
you might think it has something to do
with the maritime industry or something
to do with seas right well i'm sorry
but it's nothing like that the
initiative is so named because it links
12 european union countries located
between
three different seas the baltic sea to
the north the black sea to the south
east and the adriatic sea to the south
west
we are talking about austria bulgaria
croatia slovakia slovenia estonia
hungary latvia lithuania poland the
czech republic and romania it is a
movement created in 2015 to carry out
projects in three areas
infrastructure energy and
telecommunications its objective to
foster economic growth in the whole
region and i can already tell you that
despite being fairly recent the three
seas initiative has given rise to more
than one controversy both
inside and outside the european union in
short it has the support of the united
states it angers russia and it worries
some eu countries but where does this
project come from what exactly does it
consist of how far could it really go
and could it perhaps even become a
threat to the european union itself
at least as we know it today well we're
going to take a look at that
right now
central europe's comeback
[Music]
as we've already mentioned the three
seas initiative unites a whole swathe of
countries from estonia to bulgaria and
the idea of connecting northern and
southern europe is far from new
what has not changed this time is its
main promoter which is none other than
poland poland is stronger than at any
time since the 17th century
says president duda nfp andre duda is
the president of poland the country that
together with croatia has launched the
three seas initiative and you're
probably thinking
so why is he talking about the 17th
century well this map
explains everything
what we see in green is the territory of
the polish lithuanian commonwealth we
are talking about a federal state
created by the union of lublin back in
1569 which reached its peak in the 17th
century for poland this was a golden age
something like the 20th century for
hollywood however
the commonwealth as such had a very
short history at the end of the 18th
century this territory saw not one but
three partitions between its large
neighbors austria prussia
and russia as a consequence both poland
and lithuania did not become independent
again until after the first world war in
the second polish republic was created
an independent state but one which was a
far cry from the grandeur of the 17th
century and it was precisely then that
the idea of recreating the former
commonwealth in one form or another
began to take hold
[Music]
[Laughter]
as donald trump might have said if he
was born in poland at the time znobu
ushilik polsky
something like that anyway i'm so sorry
poland on behalf of my pronunciation for
your beautiful language in case your
polish is rusty like mine certainly is
that was
make poland great again although the
truth is that in order to make this
promise it did not take a donald trump
because the second polish republic
already had a leader who was fully
committed to this message we are talking
about ugh
joseph piusky i'm so sorry poland
[Music]
piusky was the first head of state and
20th century poland and his great
concern was the pronunciation of his
name by foreigners now i'm kidding his
great concern was in the east initially
the russian empire and later the soviet
union
in fact under puzzles command poland
fought a two-year war against the future
republics of the ussr and of course the
big question is
what could a country like poland do to
survive well puzky had two proposals the
first option was to break the enemy from
within
as you know that as far as nationalities
were concerned the russian empire and
later the communist project were
anything but homogeneous thus suzuki's
idea which received the name
prometheanism consisted of promoting
anti-russian and anti-soviet attitudes
among the different peoples that made up
the ussr however pyzotsky's project that
resolates most of this video was the
so-called intermarium which covered the
territory that lies between the baltic
black and adriatic seas so what would
this territory look like
to us exactly they are the same
countries participating today
in the three seas initiative
[Music]
was a political project between the
countries located within the territory
of the former polish-lithuanian
commonwealth in this way purutsky
intended to create a new core of
regional power and to find strength in
union but with poland as the leading
voice
the idea was developed by other polish
politicians in the interwar period but
the truth is that it did not find enough
support abroad it ended up becoming a
failed project
[Music]
but then why are we talking about it now
on visualpolitik well because for many
analysts pierutzki's ideas are the
clearest antecedent of the three seas
initiative judge for yourselves we are
talking about the same territory a
certain antagonism with russia and a
project from which poland
has much to gain however there is a very
important difference between the enter
marium and the three seas initiative
pyrotsuki was thinking about the
integration of the countries in the
region with geopolitical and military
aspects as the basis of the project
in contrast the three seas initiative is
no longer a project of integration but
of coordination and has much more of an
economic
background but wait a minute because
here we have to make a side note
it is true that the new initiative does
not make provision for cooperation
in military matters but it is also true
that with the exception of austria all
the countries of the three seas
initiatives are also members of nato in
addition
nine of them are part of a regional
regripping known as the bucharest nine
the b9 was created in 2015 at the
suggestion of romania and poland and
aims to harmonize
regional preferences within nato in
other words if we combine the three seas
initiative with the country's membership
in nato
and the b9 then what we have is a
project much more akin to porrowski's
enter mariam now at this point i'm sure
you still have many questions what
exactly does this initiative entail why
is poland so interested in it and what
are the consequences for the region and
beyond do you want to know more
check this out
connecting europe
in 2015 the presidents of poland and
croatia agreed to create the three seas
initiative it should be understood that
for the time being
is not a new international organization
but an informal movement
so far the initiative has held five
annual summits and the sixth will take
place in bulgaria in july
2021. its main objective is to promote
economic growth in the region and
reduce the group's energy dependence on
russia therefore its key three project
types are transportation
telecommunications and energy
to date we are talking about 90 projects
in various stages of development for
example one of the projects proposed by
hungary is the so-called north-south
connection as the name suggests it
consists of creating a transport
corridor from sweden to greece passing
through poland the czech republic
slovakia hungary croatia
serbia montenegro and macedonia and
although some of these countries are not
even
part of the three seas initiative what
matters here is the ultimate
goal to promote connectivity between the
north and the south
of the central eastern fringe of europe
in the digital field we also have
very interesting projects and areas as
varied as 5g cyber security and
real-time monitoring of hydrographic
basins
but perhaps the most important sector is
energy if you are regular followers of
visualpolitik and why would you not be
you are well aware of the issue of
energy security in europe and you also
know what one of its main sources of gas
gases
of course we are referring to
[Music]
40 of all gas imported by the european
union
comes from russia as you can see russian
gas
is particularly important for some of
the countries of the three seas
initiative this translates to an
invaluable geopolitical tool
for moscow precisely because of this
countries such as estonia latvia and
croatia are working on the creation of
liquefied natural gas terminals that
will allow them not to depend on gas
pipelines and therefore
not on russian gas liquefied natural gas
or lng is transported in giant lng
carriers and the advantage of this
system is that it opens up
many new import channels for example
since 2017 poland has been importing
liquefied natural gas from the united
states
it all sounds great so far doesn't it
well hold on because it's time to talk
about the main problem with the three
seas initiative
and some of the projects for example the
north south corridor are on hold because
it is not at all clear how and when
they'll be implemented and above all
where on earth will the money will come
from to finance it remember we are not
even talking about a formal agreement to
date only two of the 90 projects have
been completed and both were national
and scope
the solution in theory this could be it
polish and romanian banks established
three seas investment fund emerging
europe
the investment fund was created in june
2019 and is the first formal institution
created under this initiative it was
initially endowed with 520 million euros
that's 616 million us dollars a figure
that has grown to 1.2 billion or 1.4
billion us dollars at the time of making
this video of course
it's still a long way off from its first
target which stands at 3 billion euros
or 3.6
billion us dollars the idea is that this
fund would finance around 9
of the proposed investments in their
first stages the rest of the financing
would have to come from national coffers
and european funds such as the european
investment bank the european bank for
reconstruction and development
and the connecting europe facility of
course if this fund has served any
purpose it has been to confirm that the
3si the three seas initiative is
beginning to arouse
interest outside the region take a look
at this
300 million dollars for the three seas
fund by dfc
3cs.eu now why does the united states
care so much about it to what extent
does it threaten stability within the
european union
and what does all this have to do with
russia check this out
flood risk
the 3si even though it is still very new
is already starting to arouse all kinds
of reactions and this is no small matter
as a whole the 3si is made up of 12 of
the 27 eu countries which which presents
of the eu population and 28 of its
territory
what's more with the exception of
austria all of these countries have only
joined the european union since 2004. so
their history as part of the eu
is quite recent for this reason the
creation of this initiative has been
seen by some countries as an attempt to
challenge the europe of the 15th that is
the states that were part of the eu
before 2004. this is so to speak the
other europe that the european union
welcomes a europe very different from
the one we are used to
europe that is not always comfortable
with brussels does this mean we are
facing a project that could shake the
foundations of the european union well
in fairness for the time being it
doesn't really appear to be a threat to
the european union in the short term
anyway
at the moment we are not talking about a
formal structure the packs are still
limited in scope and also
not all countries are aligned in the
same direction for example slovakia and
the czech republic are not yet part of
the 3si investment fund this is partly
explained by their misgivings about
poland
and to a lesser extent hungary in
addition the financing of the projects
that are being implemented today
depends on a large extent to european
funds but
wait a minute this does not mean that
this initiative could not have
significant consequences in the medium
term the 3si could help unite the
countries of eastern europe push them in
the same direction and
increase their presence in brussels if
necessary the alliance could even be a
counterweight or they could limit eu
actions let's not forget the whole
brexit saga
[Music]
for example the 3si's energy plans clash
with nordstrom 2. we recently told you
on visualpolitik that nordstrom 2 is a
pipeline that will soon bring russian
gas to germany despite criticism in
central europe and this is where another
player comes to the fore the united
states
while russia hopes to hold our european
allies hostage with their nordstream 2
pipeline the 3cs initiative
seeks to counter their malign influence
adam kinzinger
u.s house of representatives for
washington supporting the three seas
initiative is a good opportunity to
counter russian influence in the region
so much so that in november 2020 the u.s
house of representatives unanimously
passed a resolution in favor of the 3si
not surprisingly therefore the project
is of concern
to russia which suspects that their
three seas could stifle its interests in
the region for example in the opinion of
the russian ambassador to estonia the
three seas initiative could become an
anti-russian cordon
sanitaire understand that this side of
europe is much more connected to
washington than has been the case lately
in the former western part of the world
basically ex-communist europe is gaining
more and more influence its economy is
thriving and its political clout is
growing initiatives like this one even
if they face
all kinds of problems getting started
may end up becoming a turning point for
the old continent's politics but at this
point the questions are over to you do
you know about the three c's initiative
do you think it will be able to carry
out all of its projects do you think it
could
even become a threat to the european
union you can leave your answers
in the comments below and if you found
this video interesting don't forget to
like hit the little bell down there and
subscribe to visualpolitik take care
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you